given all your experience and all the
different ways and you think about
martial arts and violence
in Mexico in the in the world speaking
of hoys
what is your approach to conflict uh
like a like a street fight what advice
would you give people in the full
spectrum of what a street altercation
might entail what is the best way to
approach it I think before you get there
you have to prepare you know so like one
of the first things I tell people is uh
if you don't have a basic T Triple C
training class behind you you should
re-analyze your your life and your
ability to prepare to be Triple C
basically how to stop somebody from
bleeding out or dying from a stab wound
gunshot wound or any of those types of
wounds or an amputated leg during an IED
scenario anything you would see in a
Boston Marathon Marathon type event or a
Vegas shooting event where people are
getting shot stabbed cut so understand
how to help people how to help yourself
post you're no good you don't want to be
a you don't want to be a detriment to
the situation you want to be an asset so
build yourself up as an asset for in a
situation like that because you might be
doing that on yourself or on somebody
else and also it helps you understand uh
what situations are going to result in a
lot of
in a difficult situation to deal with
afterwards yeah it also teaches you what
to stab and what to shoot if you're
thinking about it in a full and on all
the dimensions of it you know you know
there's there's all weapon all knowledge
can be weaponized and I think that's the
approach of all people should kind of
figure out for themselves when they
start getting ready or if they want to
take the responsibility of their own
safety in their hands so in a
self-defense situation there's a lot of
questions here but what what does one
stab
there's the carotid arteries which are
used commonly in Jiu Jitsu is something
to choke because they feed a computer
you know so there's a lot of blood
flowing through that required for the
successful operation of the computer and
not a lot of stuff is guarding the
outside world from your carotid arteries
that's a really weird design by the way
it is not a smart one it doesn't even
make sense because with mammals they
bite each other's neck like why can't
you have more
protection because this is the only like
us humans don't use their mouth to kill
each other but most mammals most
predators do it's like why the hell
don't we protect this we do have a
defensive mechanism and you you see it
sometimes when people are ambushed and
people try to open up each other's necks
from behind
if you push somebody's neck forward the
carotids will actually lower themselves
and be encased in more flesh and muscle
if you pull a head back not so much so
that's a way that at least I think the
evolutionary we've have a defensive
mechanism for that uh there's a few
videos out there of people's getting
their neck sewn back shut after somebody
pushed their head forward to try and
slice their necks and they survived you
know
um so this is a viable Target uh the
heart is another one interesting about
the thing about the heart and people get
alarmed when I talk about this and show
it in classes
uh again a lot of the classes I do are
for orientation and to for people to
recognize that behavior so a lot of law
enforcement comes to some of these
classes though oh that's horrible that's
how somebody will kill somebody yeah
this is how people that know their thing
their [ __ ] will try and approach
somebody and stab you to death This Is
How They would do it
uh there's a tendency to
view what we see in John Wick or view
what we see in uh this martial arts
Community where they're you know slicing
and dicing people different myriadders
of ways
a lot of that is based on dueling based
cultures like the Filipino martial arts
or some of the Italian martial arts out
there where somebody's facing off with
somebody else with a similar weapon
where both of us are agreeing to
basically get into a stabbing
competition
that would make sense in that scenario
in that context but I've never seen a
lot of people actually get into these
one-on-one knife altercations
um what we see now in a modern context
when it talks about weaponry
is an ambush counter Ambush based uh
scenario where somebody pulls out a
knife turning a grappling situation on
the street or when somebody turns a
striking exchange of punches it punches
into pulling out a cheap gas station
knife or
a pen or a rock from the ground or a
handgun most modern combatives when it
comes to Weaponry should be kind of
based on the whole aspect of Ambush and
Camera Ambush there's a lot of people
showing uh valuable kind of material and
coursework on this out there
um my whole approach and my specific
kind of Realm is in the aspect of how
people go from the process of learning
some of these things from experiential
stuff people that grow up in rural rural
places grow up on pig farms that
actually get the experiences of process
in the pig for example or processing an
animal those people will have more
skills Hunters those people will have
more skills with a knife if they pick it
up as a weapon then
most of the martial artists that I've
seen kind of approach some of these uh
classes where I go and have a simulated
torso in the form of a pig hanging in a
room somewhere
some of that has to do with just the
the familiarity and the comfort of just
like the biology of a living organism
like that you if you cut off certain
things if you cut a certain thing like
it's just a meat vehicle the same thing
you know the medical training should
come first you know or if you don't have
that be a hunter or go to a a Butchery
class that will teach you more about how
to use a knife
on somebody else than anything you know
that'll that'll give you the experience
of Flesh uh most people you know I do
this example every now and then where I
have people bring in a
a tactical knife and they'll bring in a
butter knife and I asked them which will
go through a torso we have a pig there
so it simulates a torso pretty closely
most people will say nah that butter
knife's not going to go through and it
does you know it does go through it's a
thin enough strong enough sturdy enough
that it'll go through
um kitchen knife
a cheap one that cost 89 cents at uh at
a Walmart and a expensive 400 one yeah
and the the cheap one will outperform
the expensive one it was the tip will
snap off uh during some of it
yeah I have to say that it just is a
small uh tangent I went to farm
and uh just seeing the butchering of
meat and so on uh in the processing of
me and pigs and cows
that's uncomfortable yeah but I think it
also it's honest and wrong like that's
something that probably everyone should
experience regularly uh
because it it's also humbling to to
remind you like when I um
I had a dog Homer he's in Newfoundland
that was I was very close with and uh we
lost them and I I just remember that
carried him he's like 200 something
pounds and it said to carry him I had to
put him to sleep and like one of the
biggest realizations is like oh this is
just a this is just a biological thing
yeah it's just and then to to realize
that this is just meat
this is not and you can cut it
and then you if you bleed you all of a
sudden the life can disappear from you
yeah and it's all gone it's like holy
[ __ ] there's this meat vehicle that some
people have referred to as Lex
is I'm just a few stabbings away from
like leaving yeah I'm leaving goodbye
that's a soul that just flies away yeah
it used to be that we had to hang around
you know people would come back from
battling we would hear things next to
the campfire
as far as oh he stabbed somebody here
and this happens but now we live in an
age where you can you know when I do a
class I this is this is a stab to the
heart and here's like five videos of it
happening live you know on live leaks or
whatever and we can deconstruct that not
only that but what weapon was used oh it
was a gas station folder it was a
Pioneer Woman knife from Walmart with
flowers on the handle you know whatever
it was uh and people start realizing
that it doesn't take a lot
that it doesn't take a lot of training
because a lot of these people are not
high level assassins trained by ninjas
in the Hills or anything like that there
are people that grew up rurally or
learned by seeing that behavior in
others
and when they start coming to the
realization that it's pretty easy to do
that and they start figuring out like
how do you counteract that well number
one learn the behavior yourself so you
can recognize it the whole aspect of
being a good counter Ambush team is to
be a best the best ambusher in the
planet
so again the whole aspect of Musashi
saying know your enemy know his sword
you know you figure that out as far as
learning that behavior
you know when you start seeing how some
of these stabbings occurred occur the
first thing you notice is that one of
one of the hands is always kind of out
of the picture or there's a lack of
symmetry in the people that are about to
do something horrible
so when you see lack of symmetry in the
environment somebody with their hands
going backwards
um there's a crowd of people and some
and and two or one individual is looking
counter where everybody else is looking
or there's a hyper-aware individual in
the crowd uh the hyper aware are always
usually out there to [ __ ] somebody over
or are there trying to keep those
Predators from plucking somebody else
over so
unless you step back and you put
yourself in the process of learning how
they learn and you become that potential
nightmare person it's hard to recognize
that in a crowd it feels like one of the
significant ways to win or as a street
fighter is to avoided by sort of sending
pacifist signals in every way meaning
avoiding the situation whenever there's
like
uh like a hyper Vigilant people you just
kind of avoid signaling that you're one
of the players of Interest yeah if we're
talking about counter Ambush at which
point
do you do that versus shift to the
aggression yeah I think violence should
be always an option you know everybody
should have that option and you need to
be good at that option I think uh I
think I heard Jordan Peterson talk about
the fact that everybody needs to be
dangerous but keep that [ __ ] under
control you know yeah I think he was
referring to a different context but I
don't know I know I'm referring to the
ability of the little physical conflict
uh there's two cases that I saw of
people just utilizing social engineering
to a beautiful degree to de-escalate
[ __ ] right one guy uh somewhere first
off if you're in a place where people
are grabbing your wife's ass or
something like that like what are you
doing there you know there's a load of
things that are wrong with everything
that you're doing in your life to be in
that environment but yeah let's say
you're in an inescapable situation
there was this guy who was in a
compromised position uh somebody wanted
to fight him uh like legit kick his ass
and he said okay uh I'm let's go but I I
just I need to warn you that I have
Pepsi before we go outside
and that is masterful I was getting my
phone out to to film this you know maybe
uh and even I was just lowered my phone
to give him a slow clap that was a
beautiful move you know
um and then there was this other man uh
there was a there was a riot somewhere
in uh in Ensenada the municipality went
in Baja they were protesting some of the
people that picked those fields down
there part of a tribe called Los trigis
very Hardy hard-working people but
nefarious people too they're they're
pretty they're pretty good at their
thing
um
there was a riot line they couldn't
break
and this old man walks in the middle of
the right line and yells grenade and
throws an avocado in the middle of all
the cops and I'm like
you broke that rye line with an avocado
that could have gone wrong in so many
ways but it didn't I don't know to me
it's like it's there's small lessons
there there is a case to be made about
social engineering about learning about
Behavior but learning how to lie and how
to kind of move your way or navigate
your way around situations like that
small things like bartering knowing how
to bribe people in Conflict zones is the
thing that I I show when I talk about or
train people to work in hospital
environments
de-escalation you know is specifically
kind of figuring out what is a value in
the environment what things you
shouldn't be doing in an environment
that might be considered disrespectful
or out of place you know the people have
a tendency that that it didn't grow up
in places that are violent to make
continuous eye contact with somebody
maybe that might be a issue
or smiling when there's nothing to smile
about I think you know uh there's a
picture I saw somewhere of Russians
taking a a portrait and there's
Americans there and the Americans are
smiling but the Russians aren't yeah
because what is there this file about
which is true and of course it's not as
simple a smile or not smile there's
subtlety to it like you said eye contact
this is a super interesting one because
um
I found in my in my own life like not
making eye contact is
other people would be joking but it's a
really powerful way to de-escalate and
there's such a fascinating thing though
because you could talk about drunk
fights that are just
uh that are harmless but I feel like the
same Dynamic applies to the most violent
conflicts including Wars I feel like ego
is part of this so to me the question of
conflict whether it's a street fight or
anything else
is the calculus of are you willing to
taken out
uh in terms of psychology somebody grabs
your wife's ass you mentioned
boy if you let that happen you go home
you don't have to pay the price of you
were the person who didn't Define you
like in your relationship yeah you
didn't defend your wife's honor yeah
you're gonna psychologically pay that
price yourself and
depending on your wife she might
secretly also lose a little bit of
respect for you yeah now how you play
that calculus because now we see the war
in Ukraine
I would say there is elements of similar
posturing in the United States in in
Europe in in Ukraine Russia China
leadership
at a geopolitics it's still somebody
grabs somebody's ass
and you're not backing down so to take
those losses and basically just posture
you know lower your head and live to
fight another day type that situation
the thing with modern violence is you
know
the access to Weaponry uh you know and I
mean again nobody owns life but anybody
can hold a frying pan can own death I've
seen people
um you know get double leg take down
somebody on the ground it's a different
thing doing the mats versus concrete
that's a good way to kill somebody you
know the the most prolific impact weapon
on the planet is the planet itself you
can see various videos of people online
where they fall and they hit their head
or somebody hit their head and they go
into you know the stretched out fit
basically uh and that might not kill you
then but it'll kill you that night or
the second night if you don't get
checked out you know people bleed out
internally get an edema again the whole
aspect of me showing how some of these
things
not only some of these methodologies and
somehow people prepare for violence and
how people experience violence how they
make their weapons how the people fight
in the streets and stuff like that
is to recognize that behavior from the
Inception you know uh there's a video I
show where there's a bunch of Street
kids in Rio de Janeiro I think it's
during the Olympics where they're
snatching Janes and cell phones from
people and it's a fun video you know see
it and it's uh the first thing you learn
about it is how they Target people
now who are they going after there's a
bunch of people there why are they going
after that specific person
and you start learning about profiling
and how they identify victim mentality
you know or the Vic the perfect victim
you know lack of awareness
they keep on a straight line avoidance
avoidance of eye contact if they're you
know doing something nefarious or wrong
uh and how they pick who they're going
to go after you know the small people
the the women you know the the even some
of the men
and they separate the men that they're
perfect victims versus the men that's
going to turn around punch them in the
face you know what are they looking for
you know
well first off you know you notice that
the the men that are in that environment
that look at them and are aware of their
presence the hyper aware are the ones
that are not good to Target so that's
the first lesson there so it's probably
a good idea not only to be hyper aware
but to recognize that hyper awareness
than others if I want to separate myself
from the victim crap
another thing you notice is these are
kids going after some grown adults and
some of these grown adult men are with
women
and you see them you know kind of
getting outside of the grasp of the
these kids that are trying to rip their
chains off their neck or their cell
phones and they have no consideration
for the women around them uh you see
other men that are with women and you
see them grab the women and put them
behind them
and immediately they'll say this this is
the wrong one let me move off to the
next one
so that that small little lesson in the
in those videos will show you first how
these kids are growing up to profile and
Target who the perfect victims are
that's a school for them
and that is an adversarial school we
should look at that school and apply to
ourselves so in general you think
conflict ultimately the people that are
doing conflict they're looking for for
weakness I mean they're looking for
opportunity you know opportunistic
that's the Predators that's what they do
they look for an opportunity you know uh
from jumping down from a tree and and
getting the slowest gazelle to
uh looking for the opportune moment to
pounce on something that's probably big
but the risk is worth it I feel like
there's uh several motivations but but
isn't isn't there also
a her power hierarchy motivation as well
like you there's something about the big
guy that tempts you to send a message
especially with gangs aren't they send
aren't they constantly uh sort of trying
to signal that they're the alpha yeah I
mean there's I mean there's a different
situation so you could be you could be
facing a sociopathic Predator who is
looking for something in you that you
were the resource that they're looking
after
maybe it's a woman you know it could be
a group of people that don't like the
fact that you have a specific uh
nationality uh or your passport is
stamped in a specific way or that you
pray to whatever God
all these factor in
uh but in the end they all do the same
thing they look for an advantageous
position if I were to Target you I would
put you in between that wall and you
know me so you have two Avenues of exits
and I will step on one of your feet to
keep that Avenue closed so you have to
go this way so this is where my knife is
going to be you see that behavior
mirrored
everywhere in the world first off you
look for advantages right if it's
something that's unavoidable like you're
in between me and my ability to go home
or you're in between me and my ability
to feed my family
or you're in between me and my ability
to posture to the people that are behind
me the young guys that I'm in charge
I will do everything in my power
to end you right
the motivations are
not my Realm
but the ways they do it are are you know
and basically the advantage part of it
so desperation is uh
is dangerous it's a dangerous school
when I say dangerous school I mean the
most dangerous people usually come from
those
desperate environments you know you can
have uh people in Coronado holding on to
logs in the ocean and going through this
millions of dollars worth of training
and just be a professional Killers for
the government and just be these
incredible human beings
and then there's a kid that will walk up
to one of them when he's off you know
and put a nice pick right into his chest
when he's least expecting again
and that doesn't mean that one is
superior than the other it just means
that there are more that there's more
than one way to become that you know
teenagers terrify me it feels like the
intensity of desperation
like the capacity of a teenager
like 16 17 to be desperate and also not
have the matured understanding of ethics
of the world like they have this
intensity of feeling
uh that I wasn't like anything else if
they don't have a volume knob to that
yeah so it's like it's like a garden
hose without a nozzle on it so you can
regulate it they haven't developed that
they haven't learned that maybe from
somebody else or
it used to be Warrior cultures you would
you would be your Apprentice under
somebody or you would learn some of
these things from other people even some
gang modern gangs have a little bit of
that
but if you're not and you're just this
kid that's been playing Call of Duty uh
all of his life or that has been
witnessing violence and media and
there's no
sense of
it's probably a bad idea to go off and
do this because all these repercussions
I could see how that could be uh danger
to society and some of the volume knobs
some of the countermeasures the people
exploding on somebody else with a well
with a weapon you know that you see
videos constantly online I remember
seeing this one of these two uh
teenage girls somewhere in the US and
one of them just
there's a fight there's a hair pulling
competition and all of a sudden one of
them takes out a knife
and it just happens like that and
it's just pure and restrained
downward styling now
you're like wait where does that come
from
well uh she's from an environment where
she saw that as an option
she didn't see the repercussions of it
and she found herself in a place where
she thought that was the only viable
option pulling out a weapon
and that's I think that's that's the
dangerous part of it
so how do you prepare
uh to win those kinds of situations to
escape those kinds of situations
like you said this training it's
exposing your mind I always tell people
like if you don't have a combative base
you don't have a base
uh boxing Jiu Jitsu and that that gives
you what like an awareness of your body
kind of thing it gives you an awareness
of your body you give you a spatial
awareness if somebody if you if you
can't see the points with your
peripheral vision if you can't see the
points of somebody's feet in your
peripheral vision they are in range to
stab you in the heart if they wanted to
and that's something you learn from
boxing that you learn from Jiu Jitsu you
learn from a bunch of combat Arts where
you learn about distance and angling
people
that comes from this experience that you
have you know again a lot of these
things were just a horse play when we
were growing up in some cultures or
you know Rough and Tumble with your
brothers and [ __ ] like that but we're
some of us are growing up in single kid
homes now and we don't get that we were
missing that and if you don't have it
then you find it in the
you find in a Jiu Jitsu gym you find it
in a boxing gym you have it you find it
a Thai boxing gym you find it in places
where they specialize in
focusing on certain aspects of this
whole combative hole right it used to be
before UFC you know we the Kung Fu man
you know that Kung Fu guy that's just
Street Lethal [ __ ] you yeah you can't
use it in the sporting car you can't
show you this because it'll kill you now
we pretty much know that most of that
was
you know flights of fans here BS and it
pains me too man I wanted to learn some
of the dmac single punching and killing
technique you know I remember those
books but that's just not still on the
lookout for that maybe somewhere I don't
know you know maybe you should put a pen
in your hand that that might turn into
that but yes that's the only way that's
the only way right but uh a lot of these
myths are kind of like faded away and
now you see people that have different
combative bases combining them all and
becoming a fighter now
that's the UFC fight two people fighting
each other is one thing you know you
being in the middle of the Portland
riots and a bunch of state troopers
throwing gas at rioters and then Riders
themselves fighting each other and you
finding yourself in the middle of that
that's a completely different thing
and if you think you're gonna you know
go on go on the ground and get in a
guard with a with a with a guy swinging
around a shovel a piece of a shovel
handle right as tear gas is going on
because you've got uh stop there and
your car was you know windows were
broken and your family's in the back
seat
you know that is a different situation
so
you know I'm getting medical uh
learning how learning about Weaponry you
know uh I I personally don't really like
fighting on the ground
but that's why I force myself to go to
the train with different people out
there you know uh the on the ground Jiu
Jitsu cash wrestling to top and bottom
neither you don't like either I
personally I like being in a car and
running everybody over that would be
great you know if I could or driving
really far away or uh
I had this I had this experience in Utah
uh some some friends of mine a military
uh some of your best Shooters and some
of the best years in the US you know
coming from the uh the Marine Corps
we're showing you were showing me how
they you know would shoot something from
really far away
and I was like oh
you don't even have to be in the same
vicinity
the scope of violence and how far you
can be from it or how close you could be
from it just wait till we get to see
what we can do in the Cyber attack world
we can destroy your whole well-being
your whole life your identity that's
another aspect of it too financial and
then uh figure out where you live in
terms of Ambush yeah figuring out
everything about you such that hurting
you is easy I have a class where we
specifically work on social engineering
and kind of
how how you can go about something that
you know on a micro level uh we I do a
class with a guy named Matt Fiddler who
does uh basically he's one of the
Premier experts on how to get into and
bypass locks basically
yeah you'll we he'll show you how to
open up every single bypass every single
commercial lock available in the United
States like he'll spread it out to open
up everything and that's like
right and my part in his class is I talk
about how you can pull some of that off
in a public space and not get caught or
how you would employ some of these
things in a context where it's like
useful for law enforcement for the
military stuff like that
and uh so we have this exercise in a
public space where there's a bunch of
padlocks in the environment right and
they be painting pink so people know
it's our padlocks and we're not breaking
into anybody else's padlocks if we get
approached and asked about it
but I asked the students like so you
have to gather all these padlocks from
this public space you know so how would
you do it so a lot of them are trying to
pick them you know they're like it's
very suspiciously picking them and stuff
like that that you get caught and it's a
whole situation
but the Smart Ones Will basically
develop a social media campaign related
to the bat box right
a beautiful a beautiful example of this
and this actually happened here in Texas
I did a class out in Dallas
we put the padlocks all over this public
mall
and the students basically came up with
a breast cancer awareness campaign
online that they they made fake uh well
they made flyers for it they did the
social media page on a campaign
they did this email chain so when they
went there people were expecting them so
they normalized the behavior through
social media and they were walking
around with bolt cutters in the middle
of the mall cutting these things off
that's a beautiful yeah that's a
beautiful solution to a complex problem
that nature and again
web the weaponizing part of it anything
could be all knowledge could be
weaponized and it's if you focus on
getting in a street fight with somebody
with your fist or a knife you know
you're missing out on the whole
complexity of violence in in the way
that it's now being utilized